so we know why the administration is
doing this are trying to change the
population of the United States and it's
absolutely working better than anyone
ever imagined but for well really two
years now we've asked why is Texas
allowing this Don't Mess with Texas well
Texas is being messed with in a very big
way
and the governor of Texas Greg Abbott
just won re-election by opposing open
borders last November he said he would
deploy a total of ten thousand National
Guard troops to the border to fix the
problem and keep four Nationals out
because we have laws in this country
but in fact the actual number of
deployed troops was nowhere near that it
was about five thousand according to the
Texas Tribune keep in mind Texas
National Guard has about 20 000 troops
so we've asked maybe 15 times on the air
where are the soldiers to stop this and
save the rest of our country
to on Tuesday Greg Abbott did deploy a
small number of National Guards members
state troopers through the Rio Grande
they formed a line they blocked dozens
of migrants from surrendering to border
patrol agents on the other side it
worked
the border patrol stayed behind the
National Guard they couldn't process the
migrants and release them into the
United States
so the truth is Greg Abbott is a
governor of one of our most important
States maybe the most important state
actually he's commander-in-chief of his
State's military forces he could order
the National Guard the entire border
right now
and so why hasn't he so again we've
needled Greg Abbott countless times on
the show and asked why and tonight he's
agreed to come on and explain him we're
grateful for that govern rabbit thank
you very much for coming on so just a
very clear question why two years ago
not say I'm the governor of Texas
they're messing with Texas I have a
military foresight command it's called
the National Guard we're going to block
the border and save the country why
didn't you do that why aren't you doing
that now
Cheryl Tucker I'll fully answer your
question I do have to first however
follow up on your earlier comments and
that is when you look at the disaster on
the border caused by Joe Biden if Texas
or just the Border region got just one
penny for every dollar spent in the
Ukraine we would be able to secure our
border in that budget that Congress is
about to pass they're giving money to
Tunisia but not to Texas but to be clear
Tucker about your direct question to me
there's a very easy and direct answer to
it that you could find out if you just
go through my Twitter account you'll see
about five or six days a week we're
posting images of what our National
Guard is doing on the border they didn't
just begin in El Paso during the entire
time that Joe Biden has been president
we've had thousands of National Guard On
the Border constantly first let's do the
math based upon what you laid out well I
actually don't have nineteen thousand
National Guard at our disposal the
reason is because because Texas leaves
all states in the country and having our
National Guard deployed to Regions
across the entire world and so thousands
of Our National Guard are actually in
other countries at this time others have
just returned from deployment that said
over the course of the past two years
during operation Lone Star we've had up
to 10
000 National Guard deployed to the
Border doing in other regions which you
saw them doing in El Paso what happened
is they sign up for a one-year Tour of
Duty service under Federal Department of
Defense National Guard you do one year
of active duty you get five off we don't
do that in Texas but if you get a year
if you want you get a year off however
we provided incentive incentive pay to
get people to stay on and so most people
whose time has expired for their service
we actually are able to keep them on we
have thousands on and bill malusian has
shown
absolutely but still millions of foreign
Nationals a lot with criminal records
all of them brought here by the Mexican
drug cartels have managed to come in to
the tune of 5 million more we don't know
but millions and millions have come in
through Texas
and so
first you said a lot of your Guardsmen
are abroad
were you boasting about that or do you
see that as perverse that they would be
helping other countries while not
present to defend our own
I'm saying it as a fact that Texas has
uh more of this guard that are called up
to active duty service to serve the
United States of America uh which they
are proud to do it's just but wouldn't
but wouldn't defending our own border
from an invasion of millions of people
be the single most important thing any
American could do particularly in
American underarms whom you control
well those who are here in Texas again
we we've deployed up to 10 000 of them
the only reason why it would not be more
you got to understand this also and that
is there are some who retire every
single month uh some who are no I get it
why not why not just say I'm the
governor of Texas we're the greatest
state in America every Texan I know
including relatives of mine they all
think Texas is the best you're the
governor why don't you just say any
person with military law enforcement
experience can join up we are starting
our own Force it's volunteer or just go
to Midland Dallas and Houston and get
your donors to fund it they would I'd
send you money everyone send you money
and we're going to stop this on behalf
of the State of Texas and the United
States you could do that Biden people
would back down in the face of that
determination why not
uh Tucker actually we we onboard uh new
members every single month we we do go
through both that recruiting process as
well as people signing up they on board
they go through the training process
they get ready for deployment and then
we deploy them so we are constantly
involved uh in adding to those who can
serve us on the border and they get
special training that is different what
they have to do in the state of Texas
compared to what they may do in
Afghanistan do you see this as a hair on
fire emergency that's more important
than anything they would have done in
Afghanistan or Ukraine or any other
country around the world do you think
this is the most important thing those
guys should be could be doing
Tucker I have made that point to the
United States Congress asking for more
resources so that we can better defend
our border knowing that the federal
government is not defending our border
the only people capable of doing it
would be Texas and what is Texas getting
nothing from the federal government
if you started up a voluntary fund send
Greg Abbott money people have put you in
their Wills I mean you're probably
president of the United States if you do
that I'm serious if you took control and
closed the border which you can do you
would be a folk hero sung about by
Future Generations around the campfire I
I just think it's that simple Texas once
again takes a stand against an invasion
it's not the first time you've done it
so Tucker let me tell and let me tell
you we've done exactly that I'll give
you an example I want you and your
audience to know that today we begin
putting up even more border wall Texas
is the only state to build our own
border wall my point is this we started
a fund called border wall dot TX dot uh
can't remember the rest of it we'll get
it up for you but anyway we have a fund
the people are given money to for Texas
to continue building the border wall in
addition to the billions of dollars
understand this Tucker the state of
Texas is coming out of our pocket to the
tune of four billion dollars every two
years for Texas to secure the Border not
the federal government's money
yeah well I think the long-term costs of
allowing this Trump any cost in
preventing it just my view I appreciate
your coming on tonight uh Governor thank
you very much
sure
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight